good afternoon everyone
so today's gonna be a little bit
different I deserve a little break and
coincidentally I have been sanctioned by
the powers that be to show you a
videotape going over a d-class
orientation so if at any time in the
future you need to process these people
you know how to do it so we're gonna do
that now
[Music]
[Music]
method kill agent did it act stand by
item number scp-100 emblem containment
procedures SCP one is contained on the
grounds of site zero in upstate a fence
has been constructed around the
perimeter of scp-100 security no fewer
than five armed guards are to be present
at all times
to prevent unauthorized entry the
adjoining physics laboratory will be
manned at all hours studying any
anomalies a small metal plaque bearing
an inscription will be maintained in
good condition any damages to be
immediately reported to maintenance
description SCP one is a circular gravel
path in a wooden area when traveled in a
counterclockwise direction the trail is
continuously uphill even after reaching
the original point when traveled in a
clockwise direction the trail shows the
same amount of uphill and downhill
travel as expected level five clearance
is required to access scp-1689
new members of overseer council are
required to read document zero zero one
zero five if you're reading this then
congratulations
one of us has died something killed one
of us
a monster perhaps or a rival from the
GOC or maybe we just got a little close
to the flame like Aaron not old age of
course we took care of that
didn't we anyway one of the old guard is
gone maybe Jason maybe Agnes maybe me
hell I'd be surprised if I wasn't the
next one did I I always was the most
expendable I'm going to write this to
you as though you were a human being it
will be the last time anyone extends you
the courtesy so I hope you appreciated
whoever you are whatever you did before
you must have been high-ranking when you
were pulled into this you must have
noticed the discrepancies the
inconsistencies I don't know how much
you've been told already or how much you
pieced together the crux of the matter
is this the retrievals and recoveries of
SCP objects are staged or made up whole
cloth we've never discovered an SCP in
the entire history of the foundation I
should start from the beginning so let
me tell you a story Erin Siegel was a
physicist studying at Cornell in 1891 he
was a truly gifted individual and had
his life taken a different path I
believe his name would be there with
Edison Einstein and Hawking I knew him
very well he was and may still be my
brother he was also an avid amateur
naturalist and enjoyed hiking through
the woods one day while visiting our
family home in Essex County he came
across a gravel path he decided to
follow it for a time and noticed that it
kept climbing uphill far longer than it
should have it should have taken him
above the nearby hills instead he found
himself backward he'd started without a
foot of downwards travel
another man would have assumed his
senses were faulty and left Aaron
however was his stubborn man he
investigated further
he found the path did not conform to the
pure D AMA tree of Euclid like sukira
before him he had found something
abhorrent to the nature of straight
lines he studied it the equations he
derived are part of the file you
received
you'll learn them by heart eventually he
built a small shack nearby which served
as a makeshift laboratory his first
experiments produced a key capable of
opening any lock now contained as SCP
five in others as his brother I was one
of the first he contacted I was a
medical student at Harvard at the time I
initially thought he was mad but when he
showed me the path the key I had to
learn more there were others with us
other friends and colleagues most of
them are gone now but we were the core
we created the foundation from around
ourselves in the beginning it was just
about discovering about finding the
things we could do we had such high
hopes such plans we were going to change
the world we were going to save it from
itself we could feed the hungry shelter
the homeless healed the sick and dying
Thomas Carter found us money we were
none of us poor but we ran through our
fortunes quickly Thomas used his
connections on Wall Street and in
Washington to fund us he showed them the
least of what we could do and promised
heaven against the threat of hell
Agnes Peterson my brother's fiancee was
the administrator we knew nothing of how
to run an organization we were a herd of
cats running to and fro and she turned
us into a foundation putting us dreamers
in Mad Men to the same yoke we soon had
a facility built but we were still so
secretive as much as we wanted to shout
from the rooftops what we had found we
were frightened too that it would be
taken from us we told ourselves that it
was just for the interim until we were
sure of our footing we'd show them
eventually
we'd show them all we were careful at
first we made small and offensive or
even helpful items the Fountain of Youth
the bouncing ball the civil war statue
we grew more confident and we started
working on humans a concrete man he
volunteered or the man with the
abdominal planet just a drifter but we
made him something special didn't we
it was all so easy perhaps it seems
absurd to get so many things from that
one little break in reality but it all
flowed from one discovery to the next it
almost seemed like something was helping
us along
but then things started going a bit
wrong while he was playing with his
equations Aaron accidentally derived the
missing number in my laboratory I found
I'd made the zombie plague but we were
too invested in our projects so we
pushed ahead
then came the pipe nightmare and the
stairwell we knew we'd need more help
Thomas
showed what we've done to the military
told them we'd found these things
discovered them we made up names like
Prometheus Labs and the chaos insurgency
they gave us funding personnel we built
up and expanded outward we repeated the
cell in other countries some listened
some didn't enough did we became an
international organization we brought in
more researchers though very few ever
suspected we were the source of these
items they studied sometimes we would
arrange for an object to be found by a
field team sometimes we would simply
write the reports we generated the
paperwork and we were the oversight if
we said a thing was it was it still is
there were problems of course Jeremy and
Thomas took one of our experiments and
ran off with it creating their a
ridiculous Club one of our researchers
grew mad and started worshipping
machines escaping with enough knowledge
to be dangerous
we still deal with the fallout of these
splinter groups so we contained them we
handled them we couldn't stop surely you
can see that rather than more cautious
we grew bolder I cut a little boy up and
turned him into the flesh that haze
there were reasons
there were always reasons 231 we created
her and her sisters we took them from
orphanages and arranged for what
followed and it was no accident we knew
what we were doing there was a reason
for it once but I'll be damned if I can
remember it now none of us do except
maybe my brother wherever whatever he is
now we keep moving forward
even after Abel after the blood pond
after that dam the bull reptile we still
move forward with our work what else can
we do our only hope to survive the
events we've said in motion is to
understand better to learn more we are
on the back of a terrible beast and if
we tried to jump off now we'll be
crushed beneath but that's not what
frightens me and that isn't what should
frighten you we've maintained our
foothold for over a hundred years the
things I really worry about are the
anomalies we didn't create no I was
telling the truth the first time we
didn't discover any of them but some of
them they aren't our work they just
were one day they were in containment
and they'd always been in containment
don't you see we're not in control
anymore we never were
ma'am avid kill agent did it act
standing by
[Music]
oh oh oh just um resting my eyes for a
second
oh okay well I think that's time for
lunch
don't you hope you learned something
from that videotape
it's really old but it still holds up I
think anyway thank you for watching if
you did watch and you were all dismissed
see you after lunch I would like to give
a special thank you to the reclusive
extrovert geum's Sabah Kathryn June's
Bablu ice 917 Kareem a la shmoop
Justin de Pury kuma trevor w peg white
crew NJ vucic Bryson Bailey my archive
curator neck tie verbal Burlington
nikhat on courts 563 if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos on some other cool stuff as
well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
you